descoings du pot du brun du la
composition bouquet ou chez ce fleuriste
le téléphone n'arrête pas de sonner
depuis ce matin car il est enfin arrivé
le traditionnel brin de muguet et ses
cloches porte-bonheur sont prêts à la
vente mais avec l'hiver très capricieux
cette année vous ne trouverez pas de
muguet sauvage le millier qu'on va
acheter nous à rungis par exemple et du
muguet de serre celui là arrive à terme
tous les ans et pas de soucis à la date
prévue
il le bichonne et on n'est jamais déçu
j'ai sept autres fleuristes la course
contre la montre a aussi démarré le
muguet vient tout juste d'être livrés
entre brun poser compositions de fleurs
le client trouvera son porte bonheur sur
10 mégas coupet je tirais qu' on peut le
garder à peu près cinq jours ça va
dépendre du temps c'est vrai que s'ils
continuent de faire froid bas vous
gardez votre nuque est sûre du muguet en
pot par contre là on peut partir sur au
moins deux semaines sans problème avec
les trois brins à partir de 3 euros les
fleuristes devons faire face à la
concurrence des vendeurs à la sauvette
et peut-être que les petites grappes de
la fleur danthez ferons venir le
printemps un peu plus vite